we can essentially wrap your leggings if
you want
is that okay you don't mind if my lovely
camera man
okay it's gonna seem pervy i'm so
excited charlie
carly i'm chris a pleasure to meet you
let's drop this and let's wrap up
carly's leggings
[Music]
flow off the head off the dome it's kind
of weird that i have a rap about clothes
and admittedly we're gonna aim below
we're gonna ignore the parker like a
rainbow
so many colors yeah we checked them
carly respect him
rocking the spectrum looking like isaac
newton in a suit
anyway down to the leggings oh shoot
starting with the mountain
here we go from the top down low we'll
be top with snow you got
a little thing i'm never gonna settle
when i'm on everest i'm testing my metal
to the right
yeah i get this a lot we got sticks
around a little little fox you gotta
come down here chris so you can see
bring it in closer here with me i know
it's really pervy for
us to zoom in but we got a little fur
tree i'm assuming this one
oh yes right there covering the hair
it's a little black bear
white nose gonna hunt down the honey
volkswagen beat all this right on the
money i'm not being funny i would be a
champion
if i had one of these i would go camping
like you
it's called a type 2 here's a little
outline here i try to
go to the lake that's my wish i'm gonna
go right in
gonna catch the fish but over here yeah
i got a master plan we got a tent then
we got a little wigwam
and a caravan looking like an airstream
i'm really kind of weirded out if i was
a teenage boy i'd be getting so aroused
and over here got a very cute little out
with the white wings oh yes carly let me
go down where your toenails be
tiny little sun looking like a donut and
a little bit of purple yeah don't it
rhyme with anything i don't know but
that's a freestyle rap from head to toe
[Applause]
thank you very much for letting us rap
about your undercarriage
i should apologize to my wife
immediately right here
you are
running club okay cool long distance
short distance uh i'm sure this is here
what mate how what do you do or what
did you do before the world collapse
okay he was transitioning from
accounting and now he is doing mental
health counseling
amazing i can't make jokes about that
but that's great and
where are you getting married at the top
of the bathroom
that's amazing amazing okay i'm gonna
drop a beep don't worry by the way this
won't be as bad as you think it's gonna
be
a nice long brittle white dress a
beautiful pair it's matt
and elizabeth both of them are perfect
match height corsage
i'm not being sly i'm just saying that's
not large but
he runs large distances he sees a
hundred miles he's like this is
it one step at a time from the start to
the finish
line when it comes to accounting you're
the best there is
out of the red and in the black or the
other way round up i said
maybe double entry when it's in the
ledger better than scrooge or marley and
i bet you
transitioning make less wealth but more
happy in yourself with the mental health
you do
all of the stuff that's needed to
succeed people won't commit
suicide or bleed i know it's slightly
dark
we don't need that but where are you
marrying wow
you'll both be looking so cute
presumably in this lovely dress in this
suit over there on the top
right above the clouds put the ring on
your finger stand there so proud
wearing a tiara wearing the mask there
we go a freestyle rap for elizabeth and
matt yeah
you're welcome you're welcome get some
things out you want me to rap about
and i will then rap about them for you i
hope you're enjoying the video make sure
you hit that like button and i will
release another episode of me rapping in
crested butte that's good to know
amazing and what have you got
oh this is good this is good
okay great perfect that's good let's do
this yeah i dropped the rhymes and they
stream
coming from hawaii aloha sunscreen 30
spf nothing better than that
although 50 and maybe a wide straw hat
keep the sun off your head
you got the blonde locks an inhaler case
you choke a lot your lungs fail you
you need to get it there in and puff
puff pro
air ventilating i take care of my lungs
my bronchioles and also my teeth outside
my oral holes
that's a bit of floss keep it in your
bag so if you have a kind of midnight
snack
you can take out the little bits cleanse
of the plaque purell
soothing gel don't take it back you need
that people
jacking up the prices because virus
advices you're like this you've got
plenty of hands
now hold it all of your genes yeah we
understand we know what you got
okay we succeed he doesn't want me want
to say but it's
well illegal drugs in some countries but
over here is fine
it's free grows on trees you can get
that and let me say crack a smile
if you lose your wallet you can track it
with the tile that's god's honest truth
you use the blue
tooth and here's a little thing that
will loosen your tooth
you put it on your gums the nicotine
pouch
means that it falls out of your mouth
did you know this
was a real danger of ingesting cool mint
no stranger
gives you fresh breath and gives you all
the buzz but
actually we'll kill you one day sorry
cuz
there we go thank you very much thank
you i'm glad you liked it
what would you like a wrap about
anything at all ladybugs okay in britain
ladybirds we call them isn't that weird
so yeah i know we're stupid we invented
the language though so calm down
um so ladybugs i was inspired by her
thai guy
tie-dye great paganism paganism
cool okay yeah exactly i'm gonna drop a
little beat for you guys
ask me questions when push comes to
shove my favorite insect of course
the ladybug fly away home your house
ablaze that is arson
i see a ladybug i pass one ah son i bend
down
i pick it up a lot i kiss it on his back
love the little black spots
count the number usually even but
sometimes they're yellow
for no reason it's treason committing
like a slander the queen
tie that if i was a hippie i'm keen i
take all
of my pale clothes and dip it in a usual
bowl for washing i begin with a
thick dye this is how i feel in the past
they crushed beetles and used cochineal
that's a true factor light through a
prism i shatter all the preconception
paganism
real good man let me say to you we need
christmas
it's coming from saturnalia all the
christian religions did a lot but then
this one's more recent we can call it
vin the top
drip drop i'm getting drunk off the
barley wine i love the pagan time
in the summer time and fall that's the
type of harvest festival
we burn all of the priests and best of
all the witches rise again with their
little black cat
but no more noir a tie-dyed hat is what
they like to use
they put it on their dome and then they
ride a brewstick with the kitten back
home there you go
[Music]
thank you it's even harder at eight and
a half thousand feet
with a mask in your face do you guys
have like things on you like objects
well i went to the bathroom oh no oh
you're right oh you stick it in the
woods
[Music]
okay great toilet so slides i use tampon
from the woods that's amazing and you're
responsible you didn't just bury it
napkins you stole from the restaurant
and bike lock key okay cool well let's
uh let's rap about this this is all made
up by the way it's all freestyle
[Music]
you took it without asking you steve it
there from the restaurant the napkins
you thought yeah greasy fingers give a
try how thick are they
maybe three ply why spend money yes you
all just go to mcdonald's your local
food hall
take a little bit of the paper no need
for all the kitchen roll
let me talk about this what's your goal
that your bike don't get stole
don't risk these a carabiner with a set
of bike lock keys
please keep it locked up safe and sound
while the spokes on the wheels go
round and round and this in your arms
hands your handle got a pair of the
slides and the socks with the sandals
what do your socks say here we go
there's a little hole
clone with the toe i like the collar you
put inside the thing
it protects your feet when you're
striding and walking
when you're in the crested town you need
to make sure you turn the cotton brown
or maybe rob
i'll then push come to shove you gotta
keep the cotton at the time of the month
every 28 days
it's really vital you're lying up
menstruate
that's the cycle coming to the moon
bring a little zip lock
got that time again lich watch tick-tock
in the woods
gonna take a risk crouching down people
walking past are you pit
saying no i'm just removing the string
put it in the napkin
you were asking can i borrow these don't
leave it by the trees
i use tampon in the wrap good cheese
there you go
[Music]
thank you very much guys it was a
pleasure wrapping for you have a lovely
evening cheers guys thank you
thank you for watching guys make sure
you like comment subscribe and i will
see you next time for another episode of
me wrapping in crested butter